[Musique]
une réaction extraordinaire une réaction
de joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie en à sentir lors de l' annonce
[Musique]
c'est un parcours de golf fantastique et
d'être le capitaine de cette ryder cup
est vraiment spécial c'est une journée
incroyable avec tous ses enfants je suis
très excité à l'idée de vivre cette
ryder cup à paris
[Musique]
champion d'europe dans les yvelines
grande fierté et encore merci pour ceux
qui me soutiennent fierté un objectif
terminer on est parti pour d'autres
objectifs ou encore le monde c'est les
gens qui ont gravi les échelons de gages
à main minimes cadets juniors seniors
dont quatre ont j'ai 18 ans je pense
c'est quand même une première au niveau
national c'est le top
on ne peut pas monter plus aujourd'hui
est donc pour nous c'est un honneur
d'une part et puis bon on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france pour le
beau département des yvelines
[Musique]
il y avait une super ambiance
l'année dernière nous avions gagné
contre brest ce match là était très
serré et nous avons une nouvelle fois
bien joué ici et peut-être l'année
prochaine encore regarde
[Musique]
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif
pas du bras de fer de comptoir pour vos
poignets soit bien droit qu'évoquait tôt
soit en fait je vous ayez l'épaule bien
en face que vous soyez dans l'axé médian
de la table c'est un département qui est
juste à côté de paris
mariella et en même temps c'est la forêt
c'est la campagne bat qui a tout pour
pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement avec les années
[Musique]
très positive
tous les bus étaient atteints pour viser
les choses que c'était les partenaires
les collaborateurs aussi que
l'intégration
[Musique]
on est très chanceux d'avoir eu cette
fois le cardon doublé je suis vraiment
impatient de le vivre pleinement cette
expérience de mon premier roland garros
c'est génial c'est top
carter ont forcément on s'y attendait
pas forcément mais mais c'est vraiment
un super cadeau et on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour en tirer le
meilleur
[Musique]
victoire un peu logique et pas à pas de
surprise pour moi psychologiquement et
physiquement je pense qu'on est un peu
mieux maurepas sur cette deuxième partie
de saison donc pas surpris disons qu'on
a bien préparé notre match depuis un
moment et puis on les aurait été super
motivés ils voulaient absolument la
gagner
[Musique]
c'est une tradition c'est l'histoire de
saint quentin en yvelines l'histoire de
cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et à que vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi des
lacunes des encours et quand on pense
qu'on y est il va y avoir les jeux
olympiques je pense que on a mis une
petite pierre à l'édifice pour que les
jeux soient ici quoi gens motivés à
quelques jours du départ du tour de
france pour la c1
notre départ du championnat de france
est toujours une course spéciale donc je
suis content d'être ici pas
[Musique]
c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de francesco
molinari à wentworth quand vous êtes si
proche vous voulez vraiment cette
victoire
mais c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir au genre de la télé